le Québec compte 17000 km de sentiers de
randonnée en nature des corridors
aménagés pour la marche le vélo de
montagne mais l'engouement marqué des
dernières années pour les activités de
plein air n'est pas sans impact pour la
faune notamment dans les parcs nationaux
[Musique]
si jamais une bonne nouvelle car
l'activité humaine change le
comportement des animaux
pour réfléchir à qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour continuer à rendre nos parcs
accessibles tout en assurant la mission
de conservation de protection de la
fonte que c'est parcs doivent avoir
nous on est chez eux ici et il faut leur
donner de la place et dans certains cas
c'est de l'habitat de très grande
qualité pour la reproduction
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
Jessica
sont déjà à l'oeuvre ce matin aux abords
d'un sentier dans le parc national des
grands jardins
[Musique]
elles vont parcourir plusieurs
kilomètres aujourd'hui mais c'est pour
une mission de recherche qu'elles le
font
pour Jessica c'est son projet de
maîtrise évalué par prise d'image
l'impact de la présence des nombreux
randonneurs sur le comportement de la
grande fonte
on va évaluer les faire du vélo de
montagne on va aussi évaluer l'effet de
la randonnée pédestre et de leur
ordonnée pédestre avec chien alors oui
on dispose des caméras sur les
différents sentiers pour évaluer ça
après avec les résultats d'informer les
parcs nationaux par rapport aux
aménagements par rapport aux ajustements
à faire
[Musique]
ici au parc des grands jardins dans
Charlevoix les espèces phoniques se
partagent un territoire de plus de 300
kilomètres carrés
mais les adeptes d'activité de plein air
sont plus en plus nombreux à vouloir eux
aussi profiter de ce milieu naturel
[Musique]
depuis 2019 leur nombre a presque doublé
selon un récent sondage national cette
canadien sur dix ont fréquenté un
centième nature depuis un an une
tendance à la hausse qui va se
poursuivre selon l'étude
le gestionnaire de nos parcs nationaux
c'est la société des établissements de
plein air du Québec la Sépaq
comme souvent
caméras pour aujourd'hui mais on a aussi
placé une autre caméra pour la
fréquentation humaine en bas de la du
sentier ici le biologiste Marc-André
Villard est un des instigateurs de cette
mission de recherche qui l'a lancé avec
ses partenaires de l'Université du
Québec à Rimouski on a fermé un groupe
de travail sur ce qu'on appelle la
capacité du sport des parcs dans en
termes de fréquentation donc le groupe
de travail c'est penché sur la question
ne regardait un peu la littérature
scientifique sur les effets de
fréquentation dans les airs protégées
les parcs nationaux sur la faune et on a
décidé entre autres de lancer ce projet
SI
un projet de recherche qu'il fallait
mettre en œuvre maintenant selon les
chercheurs en gestion de la faune
terrestre à l'Université du Québec à
Rimouski c'est là que nous avons
rencontré Martin Hugues Saint-Laurent le
directeur scientifique de cette étude
est-ce qu'on peut atténuer au maximum
l'impact sur les fonctions écologiques
en temps de préserver dans ces
îlots là de biodiversité et et de
naturalité que représentent les parcs
nationaux les randonneurs sont souvent
perçus d'une certaine manière comme un
risque de prédation pour ces espèces
animales là
on va l'appeler 3A point brûlés point
bas parce que l'autre caméra c'est trop
à point brûlé.o parfait sur le haut de
la montagne le piège photo il est
efficace pour les animaux d'une certaine
taille qui vont émettre une certaine
dose de chaleur et aussi qui vont être
facilement détectable en termes de
mouvement donc on est parti du coyote en
montant jusqu'à l'orignal
merci des centaines de caméras ont donc
été installés aux abords des sentiers
afin d'évaluer la réaction des grands
mammifères au passage répété et parfois
bruyant des randonneurs par exemple il y
a des espèces qui a priori serait Dieu
qui vivent le jour qui sont actives le
jour qui deviennent nocturnes quand il y
a trop de dérangement humain ça peut
être le coyote ça peut être le lynx roux
aux États-Unis puis on veut voir jusqu'à
quel point nos espèces aussi peuvent
avoir ces réponses là et les réponses
sont différentes selon l'espèce certains
mammifères vont plutôt se servir de la
présence humaine qui éloigne leur
prédateurs
ça peut aider des martres ça peut être
des serres de Virginie qui apprennent
s'approcher des humains des fois
qu'émanent carrément de la nourriture
ça finit toujours mal ces histoires là
parce que ces individus là adoptent des
comportements qui sont pas viables et
peuvent carrément être dangereux parfois
pour les visiteurs
si c'est perturbations là perdure dans
le temps imaginons à une diminution de
la natalité une diminution de la survie
individuelle qui vont changer les
nombres d'individus dans la population
et expliquer les hausses ou les déclins
de population est-ce par exemple
possible qu'on crée un vide dans une
zone puis qu'on déplace des individus
ailleurs
on a des caméras qui sont placées
jusqu'à 500 mètres des censés les plus
proches et donc on veut voir c'est quoi
l'ampleur du dérangement
il y a une nouvelle clientèle qui ne
comprend pas toujours les règles et qui
va s'aventurer à ressentir ou qui va
laisser les chiens Orly sous des choses
comme ça donc il faut vraiment vraiment
avoir cette clientèle-là à l'oeil cette
clientèle elle augmente depuis trois ans
en fait les nouveaux randonneurs sont
presque deux fois plus nombreux qu'en
2019 au Québec
un seul promeneur qui va hors sentir
peut vraiment effrayer la faune ça a été
illustré dans d'autres études
pourtant une réglementation existe du
moins dans les milieux naturels les plus
fréquentés comme les parcs nationaux
mais elle n'est pas pour autant connue
du grand public c'est ce qui explique
certains comportements inadaptés
[Musique]
alors en termes d'observation de fonds
je pourrais dire que c'est plus
difficile de voir la forme quand on
randonne dans ce parc club dans les
sentiers du Mont Orford les adeptes de
vélo de montagne prennent aussi leur
place
ce parc national est d'ailleurs un des
milieux naturels les plus fréquentés au
Québec pour les activités récréatives
le nombre de visites est passé de 731
000 en 2019 à plus d'un million 300
mille cette année
et c'est beaucoup pour le mont warfare
de qui est 5 fois plus petit en
superficie que le parc des grands
jardins
c'est bien à
[Musique]
chaland mais c'est un parc aussi Qui est
qui a des habitats très intéressant pour
la forme du site du Québec
l'habitat ici est donc très fragmenté
par les nombreux sentir récréatifs ce
qui peut dérégler les activités de
prédation et même la reproduction
d'espèces comme l'orignal l'ours noir et
le cerf de Virginie
[Musique]
ce matin Jessica et son assistant retire
les caméras installées au début de l'été
aux abords des sentiers du Mont Orfeu
le matin
c'est surprenant à quel point il y a de
la faune et dans plusieurs des caméras
qu'on a déjà retiré alors on peut dire
que la fois on est bien présente dans le
parc
[Musique]
septembre 2022 de retour à l'Université
du Québec à Rimouski salut
le directeur de recherche et son
étudiant observe les données recueillies
durant l'été dans les parcs nationaux
c'est de convertir chacune des images en
ligne de données dans la base on
s'intéressait tout à l'heure à la basse
altitude par rapport à la haute altitude
à la présence de milieu humide quand on
enlève tous ces effets-là est-ce qu'il
reste un effet des randonneurs c'est ce
que l'analyse va nous permettre de
répondre
en plus de leur bienfaits reconnus pour
la santé humaine les activités de loisir
dans ces milieux naturels représentent
une source importante de revenus pour le
Trésor public plus de 300 millions en
droits en 2020-2021 seulement alors
comment maintenir cet offre Récréo
touristique lucrative tout en protégeant
la faune
c'est un travail d'équilibrés essayez de
maintenir un accès puis une expérience
pour les visiteurs qui soient
intéressantes mais sans trop impacter la
faune qui vit dans le parc et qui est
finalement parfois relégué dans les
parcs nationaux parce que l'être humain
a vraiment occupé le paysage aux
alentours
[Musique]
priorisées pour la conservation
dépendamment où on trouve des grands
mammifères on pourrait penser aussi
peut-être à fermer certaines familles de
sentiers pour les distribuer ailleurs
s'il passe dans des secteurs
névralgiques pour des activités propres
à certaines espèces animales voire
peut-être même dans certains cas leur
fermeture et leur végétalisation
et du point de vue des animaux sauvages
dans le parc ici c'est comme dans
certains cas leur dernier refuge
pour vraiment comprendre ça pour
accepter que il pourrait y avoir
certaines limites au développement des
parcs
[Musique]